new in theaters this weekend Christopher
Robin the darkest minds and the spy who
dumped me what will you see this is your
weekend ticket okay in theaters this
weekend is the barista who dumped me
watching the spy who dumped me with my
ex best friend with the tickets that I
bought I'm not bitter but says stuff on
fire the spy who dumped me is a fun
action comedy starring the fabulous Mila
Kunis and Kate McKinnon whose characters
Audrey and Morgan find themselves
wrapped up in the bullet-dodging world
of espionage
turns out Audrey's ex with CIA and never
freaking told her that relationship was
doomed from the beginning this movie is
for you if you love movies that are
equally packed with vows and laws you
like movies about strong girl power
friendships or you've always had a
sneaking suspicion that Justin Theroux
was hiding something I do what to do
what to do what to do what to do indeed
Oh Christopher Robin no way the Pooh and
company are making their triumphant
return to the big screen this weekend in
Christopher Robin after nearly 100 years
of variations on the classic children's
story we finally get to see Christopher
Robin all grown up in this movie Pooh
and the gang must reunite with
Christopher to help him remember how to
find joy in life similar in theme and
tone to Disney's peach dragon or Warner
Brothers where the wild things are this
is certainly one of those heartfelt
classics that will make you cry and want
to hug your kids and take them to get a
waffle cone this movie is for you if you
love any of the classic Winnie the Pooh
stories feel-good Disney movies are your
thing or sometimes you feel like the 9
to 5 grind has got you down and yeah me
too remember how to be a kid again
the darkest minds hits the big screen
this weekend
based on the alexandra bracken young
adult novel of the same name this
science fiction thriller is a great
outlet for teen angst in a world where
the government freakin hates kids the
surviving 2% developed special powers
and skills that are freakin awesome the
story follows a small group of these
teen survivors on the run in search of a
place to live outside of the oppression
of the man this movies for you if you
like why a novels turn movies like
diversion or The Hunger Games you always
dreamed of having telekinetic powers or
Mandy Moore as a mother figure is just
deeply satisfying to the early 2000s you
as candy that is your weekend ticket
tell us in the comments what is more
nostalgic from your childhood reading
Winnie the Pooh getting dumped or
running from the government and check
back next week for a really big shark
and a very thin man
[Music]